sesame restaurant is a very complicated
process and you always have to first
take it into its context what is it
aspiring to be and I always judge a
restaurant from the moment I make a
reservation so the way the hostess is or
hostess with me on the phone are they
kind of condescending are they lovely it
depends you know that's kind of the
first parameter when you walk in how are
you greeted how long do they take to see
to which gives you a lot of information
about the service little things like do
they automatically give you water is the
bread warm or is it kind of just bad
brother they've thrown at the table how
quickly are you given menus are you you
explain as the menu explained to you
without going either into too much
detail or kind of just throwing the menu
at you the service are they pacing it
well are they intrusive then we get to
the food so I mean there's a lot of
steps before you even get to the food
and food is depending on what they're
what the chef is trying to aim for you
know you you always are critical or
you're judging things like the
temperature of the food when it comes
out do the flavors marry well together
are each of the the dishes the recipes
ingredients perfectly cooked cooked in
the way that they should be is it in any
way creative or innovative what is a
chef really trying to push for those are
things that also come into stark play
but for me it's very important that the
service and the food are almost
importance because you can go to an
amazing restaurant where the food is so
incredible but if it takes 25 minutes
for the waiter to bring just take your
order then I just I'm never going to go
back so it is crucial it's the Danny
Meyer school of restaurants that you
really do need to have hospitality is as
important as the food that you're served